area 15 is creating a new elevated bar  experience this looks really neat john  it's called rise it's a seven minute  ride that lifts guests 131 feet into the  air to enjoy a view of the strip  complete with some cocktails or  non-alcoholic drinks if that's what  you'd like rise opens in the fall it's  the first of its kind experience  in the u.s  and i said gosh it takes seven minutes  to go 131 feet and you said enjoy the  ride that's it have a cocktail have a  drink  have an orange juice or a yoohoo and  enjoy the the ride up 131 feet yeah i  think they really have uh is you a  nighttime drink i guess it could be any  time but wow it looks cool i really  would like to do that yeah i thought it  was a water tower but it's a cool little  venue to go look at the strip beautiful